salut à la base je voulais sortir cette
vidéo le dernier jour du mois et puis
j'ai pris un petit peu de retard au
montage donc ça sort le premier jour du
mois c'est pas tellement gêne vous allez
vite comprendre de quoi il s'agit mais
juste avant j'ai des petites précisions
à faire par rapport à la vidéo d'hier le
second degré est mort avec internet les
gars donc si jamais il est besoin de le
préciser quand je dis je suis un mytho
c'est du second degré il n'y a jamais eu
de complice dans les vidéos vous en avez
conscience de ça car non ma soeur ne
sait pas se déguiser en a mixé mais en
pierre cros désole une légende était née
et une légende vient de mourir et trucs
rigolos j'ai eu plein de messages de mes
alors si tu avais pas de lunettes avant
tu faisais comment pourvoir les
micro-expressions c'est parce que en
fait
avant j'étais pas aveugle tu vois je
voyais depuis 35 ans le même jeu conduit
des voitures
donc j'y arrivais à voir mais c'est vrai
que là maintenant je vois beaucoup plus
nettement donc ce n'est pas ça qu'il
faut se dire c'est pas comment je
faisais avant c'est que maintenant une
machine de guerre
[Musique]
le concept ce mois ci c'est de faire un
bloc durant un mois un bloc par mois il
y aura douze blocs dans l'année on ait
le 6 janvier c'est le premier jour de la
tournée mais c'est pas ça que je vous
parle je vais vous faire une annonce au
moins neuf ans que j'ai été contacté
pour écrire un livre
non ça c'était les feuilles qui avait
dessus
ouais tout à fait donc j'allais vous
dire à un gars une coupe au mois de
novembre dernier j'ai été contacté pour
écrire un livre et j'ai dit ok et on m'a
dit ouais mais faudra que ce soit prêt
pour fin janvier
le manuscrit ce qu'on appelle de
manuscrits ce que je vais rendre à
l'éditeur et là où il dira oui c'est
bien mais c'est bourré de fautes c'est
possible qu'ils aient beaucoup de fautes
il me reste donc exactement 25 jours
pour écrire les cinquante chapitres qui
veut pas dire que je vais les bâcler
c'est un petit peu comme la dernier avec
le défi de faire une vidéo par jour
pendant un an je vais là me donner le
défi d'écrire deux chapitres par jour
pendant 25 jours donc un la journée et
la nuit sur moi et je vais faire ça
durant cette tournée intensive de
janvier englobant avec vous comme ça
vous allez participer à la création du
livre directement et je vais même vous
sollicitez sur les réseaux sociaux mais
vous n'allez pas encore savoir de quoi
ça parle ou srec qu'à ce moment là dans
la vidéo pour que vous soyez directement
dans le livre de plein de manières
différentes
en attendant ça joue ce soir pour la
première date donc il serait bien que je
m'active
[Musique]
les 19h30 et on va manger avec gary
juste avant de jouer on a pris un petit
resto hazard lille où on s'appelle le
sherlock holmes de sherlock
[Musique]
la première représentation s'est
terminée ça s'est bien passé
faut quand même que je vous précise
qu'on ait le lendemain matin lachuer la
chambre d'hôtel il ya eu un vrai
problème c'est à dire que le spectacle
est à peu près une heure et demie et on
a fait trois heures de dédicaces et de
rencontres avec vous après donc ça fait
un package de 4h30 déjà tout le monde
doit détester au théâtre parce qu'ils
ont fini beaucoup plus tard que
d'habitude et moi j'étais exploser donc
je suis rentré me coucher directement
c'est un peu trop long il faut que je
m'organise différemment en fait je suis
très bavarde pipelette j'aime beaucoup
parler avec vous mais du coup trop il
faut que je trouve une solution pour ce
soir je sais pas encore comment je vais
m'organiser si je parle que deux minutes
avec tout le monde ça va mais ouais mais
deux fois 140 ça fait deux cent
quatre-vingts minutes c'est beaucoup
donc je sais pas si vous avez une idée
dans les commentaires pour qu'on puisse
prendre du temps ensemble et en même
temps sans faire le double du temps du
spectacle
après le spectacle parce que le vrai
problème que ça génère c'est que hier
soir j'ai pas écrit en rentrant donc ça
veut dire que là je vais ranger un peu
tout le monde bordel tout bombardier
juste racheté hier soir et et je peux
écrire les premiers chapitres on va
essayer ça
franchement il caffè s'il vous plaît je
viens d'avoir une super nouvelle par sms
j'ai oublié de vous le dire ce soir il
ya super connard qui vient voir le
spectacle et je suis apte ravi de bouger
en train de me demander tous les livres
que j'ai lus ou est-ce qu'ils ont été
écrits ce serait ça ce serait vraiment
cool si les auteurs ne mettez les lieux
où ils ont écrit les circonstances dans
lesquelles ils ont effet une fois je
vous ai parlé du petit journal ça
s'emmerde
et là dedans il ya toutes les idées que
j'ai cette année pour les vidéos ici je
vous installer près de moi c'est pas mal
alors pour ce premier chapitre je vais
je vais pas commencer par faire un truc
d'astuces ou de mentalisme pure et on
aura évidemment dans le livre il ya mon
éditrice qui m'a appelé hier pour me
poser une question elle m'a demandé si
je voulais qu'il y ait des rabats dans
le livre sa veine en temps en temps des
bouquins par exemple il ya un rabat ici
un rabat que deux côtés et donc j'ai
posé une question tout à fait logique
fait ça sert à quoi les rabats srm
français venant le vb écoute ça sert à
ça c'est vrai que ça sert plus à rien
les rabbins en france maintient un peu
lui livre mais il ya plus trop de sens
et donc moi si ça sert à rien s'il n'y a
pas de sens et d'utilité je ne veux pas
qu'il en est une mais du coup ça m'a
stimulé et je suis ou alors on peut les
garder mais faut qu'ils aient une
utilité faut qu'on retrouve une utilité
et j'ai une idée
et là d'un coup tu verras pas ils
servent à quelque chose oui j'ai regardé
les cimes seul avant de me coucher dans
la foule aujourd'hui je pense que je
vais écrire un chapitre sur l'otan
trajan pnl un chapitre sur le calendrier
perpétuel je sais que j'ai fait une
vidéo de l'atelier pas longtemps mais
j'aimerais bien le mettre dans le livre
sera un chapitre très course à prendre
qu'une page est un chapitre sur le non
verbal pour eux deviner la possèdent une
personne quatre chapitres les deux déjà
de retard d'hier et les deux
d'aujourd'hui j'ai jusqu'à 21h30 pour
les écrire après que merci des premiers
géants ça m'empêchera pas de repasser
ensuite dessus et si j'arrêtais parler
si je me mettais au dessus du bar de
l'irlande et à lille il ya un petit bar
privé
le petit bard des familles de stéphane
et en bois un coup là il ya quelqu'un
qui arrive en fait je ne vous dis pas
qui c'est ils arrivent ici derrière le
logo de jack daniels s'est on ne voit
pas qui c'est au mentalisme incroyable
aucune tare surprise tas en live sur
rien du tout ouais c'est j'allais dire
tu attendais pas à mixer aimes tu as
pris un peu
faut que ça dure
on est rentré avec gary enfin lui rentré
chez lui je rentre chez moi que j'avais
oublié que je travaillais aujourd'hui où
allons-nous céline winski on va au fup
cessa ofup c'est pas aux [ __ ]
non ça serait pas content sinon bah si
on pourrait aussi mais du coup au lieu
de gagner de l'argent on ira en perdre
et ça on sait pas content du tout bon
pour gagner des mes scores justice qui a
une bonne idée ça me permettrait de
faire un bon titre et une bonne
miniature pita clic et je serai donc
devant le point virgule avec d'autres
artistes pour le lancement autant vous
dire que les deux chapitres de à écrire
aujourd'hui ça va être compliqué donc
c'est à dire demain quatre chapitres mon
gars parce qu'en fait elle essaie de
faire rentrer le chat ou de chien ou
poney je ne sais pas mais cherche quoi
elle crée toujours des parfums de glace
comme ça l'a fait je râle crier pistache
puisque aux fraises pêches fraises n'est
pas de glaciers c'est un jardin les
tutos au relooking de fagnières
n'hésitez pas rester bien en place ça va
être la régalade ces normes
tu sais que moi je serais capable de
porter ça tous les jours quasiment au
tous les deux jours mais tu sais que tu
m'impressionnes tous les jours je serai
pas de moi mais je ferais jamais ça
des classes va crier vanille pour vous
situer un peu dans le temps on est de
l'uby c'est ça on est lui soixante dix
mille personnes qui viennent de nous
rejoindre sur la chaîne depuis qu'un mix
m m'a proposé de faire une vidéo avec
lui c'était j'étais comme un fou hier
soir en sortant de scène c'est il a
cassé mon compteur d'abonnés je crois je
eux-mêmes puisse et doive fumé quoi
c'est ouf je salue les les gamer de chez
am xm clap a toutefois fait d'accord
mais après tu ne touches pas d'accord
shampoing sec le diane's pense à des
gens qui ont les prendre une chose ou
qui veulent tuer des gens pour les
asphyxier cheveux gras ou prendre une
douche
fin mars on est deux
l'éloge du point virgule mens pas je
jouais là ya deux ans il ya encore les
feuilles que j'utilisais durant le
spectacle parce qu'ils sont nostalgiques
maniaque mais nostalgique et garde mes
affaires c'est une négation est ce que
ça représente quelque chose de physique
dans le réel
un objet ou un animal genre de choses
non c'est un concept plus
je pense à vous
mais c'est pas physique ça n'existe pas
dans la réalité non c
ok je crois savoir une idée je pense que
vous êtes sur le mot bien c'est ça oui
vous étiez un challenge pour moi c'est
marine bas où sont à une sale gueule
enfin bien sûr que les marines en fait
je fais développe pas bah écoute cours
pour connaître le rappela papa s'il veut
bien bien sûr prédictions à l'avance
fabien olicard
mais c'est patrick chan très réputé et
patrick chan ferais comment ça va
excessivement bien comme d'habitude
c'est patrick chan c'est marrant tu
l'aimé vraiment arrêter de l'espoir de
l'espagne agissent comme de l'espionnage
mais avec des lettres de retour au
bureau avec mélanie qui sait que dans
les commentaires il naquit demande
c'était ma meuf et way est ce que
mélanie cm me fous pas non mais la nuit
on travaille ensemble c'est déjà pas mal
j'ai fait de la paperasse depuis ce
matin donc je n'ai pas écrit le chapitre
je vais même pas expliquer à mélanie ce
que je faisais je fais un bloc durant
tout le mois je vais pas me mettre tout
de suite parce que je vais tourner une
vidéo pour vous aujourd'hui avec plein
de données à traiter et qu'il va m'aider
à traiter les données cette semaine on
ne sait pas on peut-être michel et
micheline faisait pas plaisanté michel
et micheline ici nous vous présentons
michel michel qui aspirent donc michel
qui est un aspirateur et il est pas seul
puisqu'il est accompagné maintenant de
sa femme à savoir micheline micheline
llc repli et je vais bientôt lancer une
chaîne geek parce que quand je vois le
nombre de conneries qu'on a fait ici en
électronique il nous reste en fait des
jeux que j'ai envoyé par les deux cent
mille abonnés je pense que je vais les
emmener en tournée comme ça s'il vous
voulez à la fin je vous l'offrir est
ainsi que d'aider haribo peut-être on ne
sait pas janvier
on est reparti en tournée mais ce coup
ci c'est pas guéri ses diables heures
voici mon problème pour poser leurs
ordinateurs
qui avaient vite son portefeuille si tu
étais
j'espère vérifier quel serait le sujet
de ce prochain chapitre
qu'est ce que tu aimerais trouver dans
quelques chapitres
je bats astuces ou de mentalisme truc à
fait exact qu'est ce qu'il ya hutin ça
serait bien
j'arrive à le rendre accessible à lui
tout le monde pourra le comprendre mais
avec vous nous allons observer le diable
aux orres le diable aux or en période
nuptiale fait des sons étranges dans un
micro comme pour le régler et avec son
fabuleux champ le diable aux orres
essaye d'attirer une femelle et et ça et
il ça et ça et ça ça femelle l'ats
pascal est lui répond en faisant varier
les lumières autour de l'iss
mais là pascal est ce fait pas choper
comme ça et aussi elle grimpe sur un
escabeau pour challenge et le diable aux
of melodias closer ne s'était pas choper
à pascal est il fait semblant d'orient
voire ne pas être très intéressé
regardez je pense qu'on va assister à la
coupe le monde et c'est à ce moment que
le diable other s'est rendu compte que
c'est une à mal c'était le le safari
[ __ ] c'était le safari animalier au
kef t25 alliés ont fait deux dates il
est 16h30 le public rendre à 19 heures
ce qui me laisse encore le temps
d'écrire un chapitre du livre 12e jour à
saint galmier hockey ft une carte bleue
bloqué que j'arrive pas à débloquer le
sort de la banque
je suis tombé malade je vais atteindre
cette musique là donc je disais je suis
tombé malade je crois que mon corps en
fait ma préserver surtout 2016 quand je
faisais une vidéo par jour et que là je
fais que de tomber de valence a fait la
deuxième fois je suis hs je vous disais
hier j'avais une idée et je vais le
mettre en place là maintenant tout de
suite sur facebook sur facebook je vais
vous demander de me dire cinq mots
hasard et vous vous allez pas savoir
pourquoi vous allez le savoir qu'en
voyant cette vidéo qu'à ce moment là de
la vidéo mais sur le prochain chapitre
que j'écrirais demain je me graines
comme défi de devoir placer vos cinq
mois donc je choisirais le poste avec
les cinq mots au hasard mais moi dans le
livre je veux que ce soit cohérent je
pas que ce soit en privé joe buck et que
vous qui sachiez à ce moment-là du livre
qui a une grosse connerie de cacher
alors comment je vais formuler ça ça
doit paraître chelou de faire ça mais
c'est une bonne solution pour écrire le
livre avec vous en ayant l'impression de
pas être tout seul c'est plutôt marrant
elle s'était bien joué on n'a pas vu
disparaître
[Musique]
ah bah on les met à côté d'eux à côté
des deux éléphants et du chameau
exactement 13 janvier
je suis de plus en plus malade je perds
ma voix je suis en train de ranger les
affaires j'ai fait un petit tour sur
twitter facebook tout ça j'ai vu ce
genre 2000 messages sur facebook
je crois qu'il ya 500 tweets autres
comme ça et sur le profil facebook de r3
son message de plus avec les cinq mots
que je vous ai demandé hier donc ça va
être dangereux
et sinon concernant une vidéo que vous
aurez déjà vu au moment de repérer
celles ci c'est le serai fier moutons
chèvres
je reçois tous les calculs des
mathématiciens c'est ouf c'est génial
pour ça merci youtube merci internet de
me permettre de faire des expériences
comme ça pour l'instant on a déjà
collecté 30 mille réponses
imaginez le truc le seul truc qui est
bien quand tu es malade c'est que tu as
une voix de crooner et ça ça le fait je
n'ai pas ce que ça va rentrer comme sans
la caméra bon allez je suis branché et
direction villaret oui je sais il faut
que j'écrive au moins deux chapitres
aujourd'hui je suis au courant je
n'oublie pas le but de ce mois ci
[Musique]
on commence avec une musique qui frôle
intelligence quand même elle a en face
sur du back in black est pas belle la
vie
on est le 14 on est à vienne vous
souvenez hier on était à villars là on
vient d'arriver à vienne on joue ce soir
et demain et c'est une sorte de café
théâtre cabaret où les gens mangent
c'est pas trés trés grand ça peut
accueillir 70 personnes je crois et
c'est d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt des
tournées de rodage je veux parler de ça
deux secondes parce que j'ai entendu
hier un spectateur me demandais si on
vous faisait des petites salles comme ça
si on se trompe c'est pas très grave
alors c'est pas du tout ça quand on fait
une tournée de rodage l'intérêt de
refaire des petites salles de retourner
dans le café théâtre c'est parce que
c'est le plus dur ça ne ment pas taire
si je fais quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas je le serais tout de
suite il n'y aura pas de cadeau si il ya
juste la moitié de la salle qui rit ça
fait ça fait un bon petit malaise tv
mais au moins on sait ce qui fonctionne
on le sait ce qui fonctionne pas on le
sait donc c'est le meilleur endroit pour
travailler en fait parce que dans une
salle de 800 places par exemple si tu as
la moitié de la salle qui hérite à 400
personnes qui rie et tu te rends même
pas compte que la blague n'a pas trop
marché par exemple les cafés-théâtres
c'est sans filet on peut pas se cacher
on peut pas se mentir on veut pas se
cacher derrière une grosse technique ce
genre de choc et donc tous les jours
j'ai mon diablo qui relève le défi
d'essayer de faire les lumières les sons
et combien on écrit on elven en elven ça
veut dire que j'ai pas belge avait pas
donné de nouvelles de la suite de la
tournée depuis eu ce dimanche et on est
arrivé à brignoles au famas théâtre t'as
vu
on dirait une maison c'est une maison
alors pourquoi j'ai pas de nouvelles
parce que j'ai pas continuer à écrire le
livre depuis lundi j'ai pris une pause
parce que mardi j'avais une prestation
privée mercredi j'avais un rendez vous
hier soir je joue au trianon ténors
c'est avec lui qu'on fait des pulls
angora
donc on joue ce soir et demain donc ce
qui est sûr c'est que comme je vais vous
faire la vidéo de demain matin là tout à
l'heure je continuerai pas écrire le
livre durant ce week-end mais il va se
passer quand d'être cool à brignoles
on est la veille que je vous souhaite la
vidéo sur le fait d'avoir un deuxième
trophée youtube vous le savez pas encore
au moment où je vous parle mais j'ai
reçu deux trophées youtube ce qui va
décaler le planning de mes vidéos d'une
vidéo je pense que ça je vous fais
participer à tous c'est terrible bref on
va au théâtre
la semaine prochaine je serai à aix en
provence et c'est là où je vais mettre
un coup pour finir le bouquin je viens
juste de finir le spectacle de brignoles
et je vais aller vous rejoindre pour
qu'on puisse discuter faire des photos
et ou avec le marqueur à ma ceinture
quasimodo
pourquoi gary me ramène ma stature et
beuzeville un spectacle et il sera mais
bien sûr j'ai mon écharpe on est arrivé
à aix en provence depuis hier avec
derniers jours eiser cherche pas t'es
mort donc d'arriver à 12h17 hier à aix
en provence et puis à cause d'un petit
problème de train très léger on arrivait
à 10h30 à marseille est formidable mais
on a vu jouer quand même hier soir
c'était cool s'est plaint des toute la
semaine s'est remplie vous êtes là vous
êtes autant ce film proche est proche
qui était passé sur ma chaîne aurillac
celui là
un mec il au téléphone et sion a depuis
que tak téléphone toujours autant iphone
4 surtout pas s
non non ce serait trop à ça que ça
ressemble un iphone c'est un truc d'un
site chinois sa valise ou donc on va
france bleu l'émission s'appelle les
tchatcheur tu fais pas cette émission
depuis depuis le mois de mai mars
dernier où un quasi un an
on vient souvent études et coiffée avec
la poignée de la porte un sein des
cannes et moir web os et si ça veut dire
que cet après midi je vais reprendre la
l'écriture du livre faut que je le
finisse avant fin janvier c'est un petit
peu à la bourre quand même
pari gagné à paris bercy 12h05 sur
france bleu provence
pas d'alerté non mais par contre ça va
être assez agité quand même surtout et
encore c'est également là que là vous
vous connaissez depuis pas mal d'années
vous êtes rencontrés sur un bateau en
turquie oui en prison
de retour dans l'appartement d'aix en
provence pour enchaîner l'écriture du
livre voici un petit bout de somer juste
à la maintenance et musique à fond dans
les oreilles et je vends qui y est je
pense 6 heures d'écriture à tout
voilà ce premier blog est terminé et en
même temps le premier jet du livre est
terminée c'est à dire que maintenant il
ya beaucoup de travail de relecture de
choses à affiner de choses à améliorer
je met cette vidéo en ligne dite moi
dans les commentaires si ça vous plaît
ce genre de trucs et qu'on fasse ça tous
les mois 7 heures une fois par mois le
1er de chaque mois je vous mets un blog
de tout le mois passent comme d'habitude
si ça vous a plu je compte sur vous pour
vous abonner à la chaîne et surtout
mettre un petit pouce en l'air qui fait
plaisir rendez-vous bientôt ciao